これじゃあはじめ冊をです皆さんのペットボトルの蓋で遊んだことあるでしょうか僕が
小6のときめちゃくちゃなんかどうでしょう前が張って行ったんですよね牛乳瓶の蓋で
公民子みたいな戦い方をしたりを3軒のキャップの部分でコマにした存在したんです
けどもそれの流れレッドボトルキャップをですねこう言うにょますゲートマーキュリー
奴がなんかすごい
流行ってたんですが小学校の時に日本に撤去民的でペットボトルのキャップで行
さ押すとチョビっと楽しいっていうっていうゲームはやってて僕はめちゃくちゃ思って
たんですよなんて思ったの人は輸入日の
立てたた仮面高を持つかしなかったのか何でも他の人はお酒のショー2たに報酬が入っ
て穴の縁の先に塗ってくるあのコマみたい熱を商品がしなかったのかなんでなんで
ペットボトルのスターでこのスピードすごい出て戦わせるのがオモチャ化されなかっ
ずっと疑問に思ってここ23年が入ってきたは所存でございますが今回なんとあの普通
に電気屋さん行ってガチャガチャコーナーコピックを見るんですけどそこで見てたら
うわっこれじゃんっても奴がありましたこちらで5つ買ってきました色がみんな
バラバラなのしていくを開けてみましょう
ボトルキャップばからいい名前だ嫌いじゃない名前の先生だっ海ブルー系でブライト
イエローをかける3た
えっ全く意味が分かりませんいろいろパーツが入ってるみたいなんですよなく作り方を
変えてるよねコツとかも書いてありましたがペットボトルの蓋でなら戦えるみたいな
ことを書いてありましたヤーもう眠い写真館僕は完璧に来たと思って買っちゃいました
いってズレちゃうぞの中見たら結構減ってなんで100円ではれたなんか皆さんなん
じゃないかなとか思っちゃってちょっとびっくりしますか挙げてみましょう
なにげにこれ全くわからん3種れるんですけどこれぞの6点と命式パーツでございます
すげーでるんだなぁ
これでようやく引っ張ったら回転するらしいです本当に入っ
うわぁ保冷風もあるらしいですね
なるほどなるほどなるほど
はからこっちじゃないんだねこうなんだね何だろうかなるほどそういうことか
思ってたのと全然違うこれはここではないか
ペットボトルではないただの方だマイナーさっき飛ばすのウィルキンソンダーナ
キャップとかも付けれるというわけですな
効果公団これでも完璧ですけど
これだけじゃなくてここから患者さまへ続くみたいですもうこういう鑑別進化しました
ペットボトルのキャップここまで進化する思ってたのと全然違うでこれをさっきの
スーパーにの設定
おおおでもすげーなちゃんと
回転するんだな
これは面白いのか来たらなぜ化髪を結っただけます
相手で全部出ました結構風がバラバラ姉御も違うして集団を違うしてる武器の部分も
全部違ってます4かなちょっと見てる
キュッキュッってるっていう
[音楽]
おおおおっなるほど本当にちょっと今から後輩と最強ドこれをつくってを食べ勝負食べ
ますそれなんだないんですよ
そんな
これじゃ絶対勝てない重すぎるからこれをこれならなんか
大堀強いよ多分ハイテク出てきました僕熱はこれで
こちら刺々しさを注い支給したこの手裏剣があったんですねこれが
得なですね日本の心をよ茶で食べさせてみましょう
なんかポイポイ頃うまく息を吐きかけてアタック
行き受けていいんだね一発勝負で手によって e 2は
うおーー
教わった
パワー
どうんだった同店だなぁ3通1項
さあ
[音楽]
えええええっ
me
ん
あっはぁ